bâtie
bonsoir la france l'amérique vient de
vivre une nuit électorale en général à
la télévision gerald ford lui était
l'hôte de giscard d'estaing au moyen de
m'échapper un dîner officiel maison au
fromage
on lui a glissé la nouvelle il avait
gagné au michigan
il a gagné dans le mari l'homme les deux
états qui votait hier un doublé qui lui
redonne un sacré coup de pouce et il en
avait besoin
tout n'est pas joué mais ça va mieux
chez les démocrates
une surprise jimmy carter le favori but
dans l'une des deux élections
ils sortent un tout jeune candidat jerry
brown 38 ans gouverneur de californie un
homme dont on pourrait bien reparler un
jour mais faisons d'abord le point
aujourd'hui
côté démocrate l'homme du jour c'est
jeremy browne que l'actuel gouverneur de
californie
regardez le bien on en reparlera les
très jeunes tout juste 38 ans il vient
de réussir l'exploit de freiner
l'irrésistible ascension de jimmy carter
dans l'élection primaire email je suis
un homme ne vais pas l'airé à la maison
blanche
voilà le thème principal de la campagne
d'autres nouveaux venus à la source la
présidente donc premières sérieuses
difficultés pour carter mais attention
c'est très important car malgré tout
chez les démocrates jimmy carter reste
très largement en effet il a obtenu déjà
6 175 voix il lui en faut total 1510 si
la convention de juillet prochain à new
york
chez les républicains maintenant grave
défaite de ronald reagan
un score très mauvais dans le michigan
sa première réaction à la télévision
américaine tard la nuit dernière cela ne
m'empêchera pas de dormir
en revanche chez les supporteurs car
leur candidat renouer magistralement
avec la victoire
mais attention là aussi pour l'instant
ronald reagan reste en tête avec 500
ivoire pour être désigné la convention
républicaine d'août prochain
il lui en faut total d'ici là milcent
voilà les faits voilà les résultats
mais comment les américains voit-il eux
l'évolution de leur écrire nous avons
évité un observateur politique
tom bishop les victoires écrasantes ford
sur rail gun dans le michigan et de
marne rend toutes ses chances au
président pour l'investiture de son
parti
précisément au moment dramatique où il
semblait sur le point d'être battue de
ne même pas pouvoir s'assurer l'appui de
son propre parti
ce serait un événement sans précédent
dans la vie politique américaine moderne
événement qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
encore exclue pour l'instant le parti
républicain partie nettement
minoritaires donnent le spectacle
surprenant de deux leaders qui tous les
deux perdre haleine
ce n'est pas le cas des démocrates 6 4 a
eu des problèmes hier il est encore loin
de perdre son élan à lui mais la
victoire important des jeunes gouverneur
brown la californie est particulièrement
intéressante comme 4 jerry brown et perd
perçue par l'électorat comme un homme
politique dynamique en dehors du système
mais je crois que brown est parti trop
tard que quatre être bien lancé qu'ils
occupent désormais une position trop
forte et qu' on ne rattrapera plus dans
cette hypothèse la 4 semble bien placé
pour battre le candidat républicain quel
qu'il soit et serait donc le prochain
président des états unis
le président giscard d'estaing bravant
la pluie qui tombe très fort en ce
moment
visite aujourd'hui les hauts lieux de
l'indépendance américaine à laquelle je
vous le rappelle la france à l'époque
avait donné vision un petit coup de
pouce les entretiens politiques
proprement dit entre le président
giscard d'estaing président ford se sont
donc terminés hier soir sur une
réception à l'ambassade de france
gregory peck kirk douglas le sénateur
edward kennedy était parmi les invités
de l'ambassade de france pour le dîner
offert par le président giscard
d'estaing symboliquement la disposition
des tables rappeler celle d'une flotte
de bateaux façon de se souvenir qu'il ya
200 ans
une flotte française a combattu au côté
des américains
autre surprise gilbert bécaud cocker
gilbert bécaud dans une chanson sur le
bicentenaire composé sur mesures avec la
complicité du journaliste américain
pierre salinger je ne suis ni la faille
est ni jefferson ni rochambeau champ de
béco simplement un frère un ami
dieu par laurent louis avec le dialogue
politique propre américains se poursuit
mais rien de spectaculaire dans les
entretiens entre les deux présidents
chacun rappelle plutôt ses propres
analyses qui souvent sont convergentes
parfois le sont moins exemple le traité
de non-prolifération des armes
nucléaires qui n'est pas signée par la
france
on en a parlé hier mais on en est resté
là l'impression ici c'est également que
dans les propos publics du chef de
l'état
les américains entendent ce qu'ils ont
envie d'entendre cela a été très net
hier au congrès où le passage du
discours le plus remarqué a été celui de
la fidélité de la france à ses
engagements
atlante passage presque uniquement
reprise ce matin dans tout après la
partie politique est formel du voyage
fhf maintenant le président explore
l'histoire du bicentenaire
c'est à dire l'histoire d'une longue
amitié entre la france et les états unis
est ce qu'il dira d'ailleurs aux
américains qu'il rencontrera dans la rue
à philadelphie houston où la nouvelle
orléans
philippe harrouard washington antenne 2
abou new york bien aux premières étapes
du président je devrais dire donc le
premier pèlerinage et pour yorktown un
port de virginie où la france il y a
deux siècles est venu se battre pour
l'amérique il y avait là rochambeau
lafayette de grâce où vous souvenez j'ai
visité pour vous il ya quelques jours le
champ de bataille
quelques arpents de terre encore
bouleversée par la bataille quelques
tranchées quelques remparts
soigneusement entretenus ces yorkton la
bataille de yorktown s'est déroulé en
1781 la guerre d'indépendance durait
depuis cinq ans déjà un terminal les
insurgés américains les révolutionnaires
américains avaient réussi à bloquer ici
à yorktown une garnison anglaise de
12000 sommes une force important alors
ils avaient creusé des tranchées amener
des canons isoler la ville mais il ne
serait probablement arriver à rien sans
le secours de la france la france a
débarqué ici 9000 hommes
la bataille dure plus d'un mois les
ouvrages doivent être en
v1 1 comme celui ci la redoute numéro 9
où l'on se battre à toute une nuit
ce sont les régiments français qui
attaque ici les agenais y les
soissonnais le régime en saintonge
le lendemain les anglais seront douze
mille prisonniers 200 canaux une défaite
irréparables pour le roi d'angleterre
qui décident presqu'aussitôt de
reconnaître l'indépendance des colonies
d'amérique ainsi sur ce champ de
bataille ici sont nés réellement les
états unis d'amérique indépendant
deuxième étape philadelphie
c'est à philadelphie sur les bords de la
deûle awa que s'est réuni le 1er congrès
des états d'amérique il était très à
l'époque pour rejeter la tutelle
anglaise et proclamé leur indépendance
était en 1776
mais tout est encore en place aline et
pau nantes or dans la salle où a été
signée la programmation la table de
chaque délégation à plumes d'oie
manuscrits et lunettes de jefferson un
nouveau monde venait d'apparaître les
américains en sont toujours aussi fier
omaha lourde à verdun bicentenaire c'est
aussi une grande affaire commerciale et
il faut bien célébrer l'événement j'ai
moi même acheté ma cravate mon badge mes
chaussettes
quand sa phrase reconnaît il a
littéralement écluser les boutiques de
souvenirs de ce bicentenaire des états
unis l'oncle sam
ma vie est une petite croisière pour
l'île de la liberté et comme l'oncle sam
est très gentil mais un peu fantaisistes
il n'a pas voulu que je l accompagne
habillant français moyen il m'a dit
débarrasse toi de tes vieux vêtements
eymétois au goût du jour alors je suis
rentré dans un magasin de wall street
et voilà comment j'en suis sorti il faut
dire que je n'ai pas eu tellement malama
coûterait de cette façon tous les
magasins new yorkais sont bourrés de
gadgets des gilets des badges des
chapeaux j'ai même trouvé ici un billet
de 2 dollars un billet de dollars qui
avait disparu depuis une dizaine
d'années et qui a été remis en
circulation
ils portent l'effigié de jefferson le
troisième président des états unis et au
verso une reproduction de la signature
de la déclaration d'indépendance dont
jefferson fut le rédacteur mais tout ça
n'est pas grand chose le véritable
gadgets de l'indépendance des etats-unis
en fait c'est la statue de la liberté
que vous pouvez peut-être apercevoir là
bas ouf
elle s'élève maintenant depuis un siècle
dans le port de new york elle a été
offert par la france aux américains pour
le premier anniversaire du centenaire et
cette statue de la liberté
vous pouvez peut-être l'apercevoir forte
dans sa main droite le flambeau de la
liberté le flambeau de la liberté est
porté par une main qui fait 6 mètres de
long est il donc le sam
à l'occasion de notre passage aux états
unis a voulu que l'un de nous a eu lui
sert et l'autre main mais je crois que
même accompagné de yankee de l'époque
héroïque
j'aurais sans doute beaucoup de mal
allez viens tonton au liban évidemment
on ne pouvait pas offrir une autre
statue de la liberté aux états unis le
jour de leur bicentenaire
c 'est déjà été fait pour le centenaire
alors on leur offre
je vous signale un son et lumière à la
maison de george washington à mende
verne giscard d'estaing doille inauguré
ce soir même s'il ne pleut pas trop car
vous l'avez vu ça ne s'arrange pas du
tout ici une autre page américaine dans
un instant à vous la france à vous pour
le faire
merci jean voici le choix que nous avons
fait dans l'actualité aujourd'hui en
france un choix complémentaires
d'ailleurs de nos éditions de 18h30 est
de 23 heures
d'abord la concrétisation autour d'un
cercueil du problème des rapports entre
les commerçants et les équipes
d'inspecteurs du fisc 300 commerçants du
20e arrondissement de paris ont fermé
leurs magasins ce matin pour manifester
leur sympathie et leur soutien à la
famille de gilbert voisins ce jeune
commerçant qui s'est suicidé la semaine
dernière après la visite d'un contrôleur
il est juste d'ajouter que cet examen
fiscale s'est placé dans un contexte de
travail intensif et de soucis financiers
pour monsieur gilbert poissant
dans la matinée les commerçants du
quartier de la place de la nation ont
voulu rendre hommage à leur tour la
mémoire de gilbert voisins en défilant
tout au long de la rue d'avron tous les
magasins étaient fermés hommage aux
défis mais aussi protestation contre les
tracasseries les agents du fisc
il faut dire que c'est une vieille
querelle les commerçants artisans
industriels n'ont jamais beaucoup
apprécié que l'on vienne mettre son nez
dans leurs comptes ce que l'on appelait
jadis et polyvalent toujours été leur
bête noire
aujourd'hui leurs proches en plus leurs
méthodes il évacue d'exercer une
véritable répression
surtout contre les commerçants
indépendants de faire de l'intimidation
de les persécuter
parfois lors d'un contrôle fiscal chez
un commerçant voisin
le contrôleur s'est permis de dire de
toute façon les commerçants sont des
voleurs et faut pas penser vous en tirez
avec rien et on trouvera toujours
quelque chose de toute façon c'est des
gens au coeur sec à l'époque j'avais ma
pauvre maman atteinte d'un cancer qui
est entre de piqûre de morphine souffre
atrocement on entendait on entendait
j'ai mis en hors bord et c'est des gens
qui n'ont pas
qui n'ont pas remis leurs contrôles qui
ont continué pour les vérificateurs des
impôts les fautes de quelques-uns ne
doivent pas faillir sur toute la
profession d'autant qu'on les accuse
aussi du côté du pouvoir de créer
volontairement le mécontentement dans un
but politique
nous affirmons très clairement que les
vérificateurs des impôts ne cherche pas
du tout à régler des comptes avec les
commerçants ils n'ont pas de comptes à
régler
les vérificateurs obéissent à des
consignes très précises et ils subissent
aussi des des mesures coercitives
si vous voulez d'incitation au rendement
ils sont obligés effectivement par un
système de notation de d'avancement ils
sont obligés de ramener des
vérifications et c'est une
responsabilité politique c'est le
monsieur focale lui-même qui se fait
gloire d'avoir porté 44 mille et
quelques et le nombre des vérifications
nous attendons que le gouvernement n'ait
pas de langage pour l'opinion publique
pour apaiser tel ou tel secteur en
ébullition et besoin pour les
vérificateurs en continuant à les
pousser au rendement alors nous voulons
que le gouvernement dans son ensemble
mais j'suis fourcade en particulier
prenne toutes ses responsabilités dans
l'opinion publique
en somme les agents du service is cool
ne veulent pas être pris entre le
marteau et l'enclume c'est normal mais
c'est d'ailleurs finalement pour alléger
leurs situations parfois difficiles que
jean pierre fourcade ministre de
l'économie des finances
allons-y après midi à l'assemblée une
série de mesures précises qui vont
devenir en quelque sorte la charte du
contrôle et chaque fois qu'il s'agirait
du premier contrôle
je demandais qu'administration fiscale
joue d'abord un rôle de conseil
avant de jouer un rôle de vérification
car il est essentiel que dans le
développement des centres de gestion
agréés par le développement de cette
fonction de conseil
la plupart des entreprises des
entrepreneurs soit capable de répondre à
leurs exigences et que les premières
vérifications soient plutôt une
modification de leur conception de la
comptabilité qu'une dure sanction
ce sont les instructions que j'ai
rappelé à l'ensemble des vérificateurs
pour que chaque commerçant ou artisan
vérifier puisse avoir connaissance de
l'ensemble de ses droits à des
possibilités de recours qu'il a fait
d'autre part indiqué que
dans chaque lettre d'information de
vérification il y aurait dorénavant le
nom et le numéro de téléphone du
supérieur hiérarchique immédiat du
vérificateur
enfin qui est en cours personnalisés et
j'ai enfin planté dans chaque
département un fonctionnaire supérieur
qui est soit le directeur des hommes
cours soit le directeur adjoint qui sera
chargé d'être l'interlocuteur pendant la
vérification pour pouvoir s'assurer que
les opérations nécessaires de
vérifications fiscales sont conduits
avec ce sens des relations humaines et
ce doigté qui est absolument nécessaire
dans une société démocratique
en bref maintenant d'abord l'annnonce de
la blessure de nos confrères français
journalistes au liban un nouveau
nouvelles victimes des combats du liban
arnaud borel photographe français qui
ont présenté au liban lagence ceci pas
été bien d'être grièvement blessé il a
été transporté à l'hôpital
ensuite la présentation du projet de loi
de programmation militaire au débuté par
le ministre la défense monsieur yvon
bourges
nous y reviendrons en notant tout de
suite l'augmentation des crédits
accordés aux budgets militaires 50
milliards en 76 58 ans 77 et 115
milliards en 82 c'est-à-dire 20% du
budget de l'état certaines réserves sur
l'orientation de ce budget sont émises
vous savez en particulier par des
groupes de députés eu des airs et
républicains indépendants 2000 à ce
degré faut demain la première intéresse
tout particulièrement les habitants de
la région parisienne puisque la cgt la
cfdt et les autonomes appellent à un
arrêt de travail de 24 heures sur les
lignes de banlieue nord et saint lazare
demain jeudi
deuxième moteur de cette fois dans les
banques demain et vendredi la cgt la
cfdt ont lancé un ordre de grève la
direction des banques prévoient
cependant à un service normal
les prix ont augmenté de 0,9 pour cent
en mars sur l'ensemble de la france
commentaire de jean-pierre fourcade
l'évolution du des prix des produits
alimentaires et des services est
anormalement fortes légère diminution en
avril du nombre de demandeurs d'emplois
en faisant intervenir tous les
paramètres techniques qui m'échappe
totalement d'ailleurs on va arriver au
chiffre de 897 mille demandeurs d'emploi
à la fin du mois d'avril ce qui paraît
confirmer le mouvement de reprise
constatée dans l'ensemble de l'industrie
enfin je vous signale la série de
mesures annoncées aujourd'hui par
monsieur michel poniatowski à
l'assemblée nationale il s'agit d'une
simplification et d'un allégement des
obligations administrés
tiff qui entoure les opérations
funéraires c'est à dire en particulier
transport des corps le ministre d'état a
voulu simplifier les formalités
d'enterrement maîtres phase qui l'a
appelé le racket de la douleur c'est un
véritable plaidoyer pour la corse autant
d'ailleurs qu'une analyse politique des
rapports entre le pouvoir central et
lille l'a prononcée aujourd'hui le
docteur edmond simeoni devant la cour de
sûreté de l'état
le premier président david avait accepté
de consacrer une partie de cette journée
à la déclaration du docteur edmond
simeoni déclaration qui est en quelque
sorte le dossier de la défense
ce n'est pas assez juge qui est de mon
simioni s'est adressé cet après-midi en
fait c'est au gouvernement france
vibrant plaidoyer pour la corse en effet
pour les corses
les corses dit il oublié sans cesse déçu
colonisé victime permanente de
l'injustice et de la discrimination
on nous accuse de séparatisme enchaîné
de mon simeoni alors que nous ne sommes
que des autonomistes contraint à l'eau
battre pour nous faire entendre mais à
nous battre au sein de la république
française
la montée de la violence le gouvernement
en porte la responsabilité historique
mais surtout conjoncturelle au moment
des événements mais si le procès montre
que nous sommes coupables
eh bien nous n'attendons aucune clémence
car nous sommes prêts à assumer nos
responsabilités
l'interrogatoire sur les faits montrent
ensuite qu'il sera bien difficile de
cerner la vérité combien y avait-il
d'hommes retranché dans la cave avec
quelles armes et quelles munitions
quelle a été la part de l'enchaînement
spontanée de la violence et celle de la
détermination
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'il ya dans ce
procès cent quarante témoins et qu'une
audience celle de demain est entièrement
consacrée à la projection de films et de
photos saisies après les evènes reste
que ce procès évolue vite puisque
désormais l'avocat général admet que les
tirs meurtriers et pu venir de la caf
mais aussi des lignes alentours c'est
très important et que les propos violent
et menaçant qui sont reprochés à edmond
simeoni dans son discours du congrès de
l'arc à corte peu avant les événements
semblent ne pas devoir lui être attribué
en tout cas la défense a déclaré cet
après-midi pouvoir le prouver très
facilement des propos qui dans l'esprit
du réquisitoire sous-tendent en partie
l'accusation d'atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état
voilà c'était l'essentiel de notre choix
ce soir voyons maintenant la suite de
l'édition américaine
à vous les états unis
henry kissinger part à nouveau défendre
la politique américaine
quelque part dans le monde cette fois il
va oslo voir ses alliés de l'otan mais
depuis un an maintenant depuis le
vietnam depuis le cambodge depuis
l'angola
la question se pose jusqu'où ira ce
repli américain reece car destin a dû
aussi posé le problème
le canal de panama ici est le seul
problème de politique étrangère qui
soulève les passions dans une amérique
tourner vers les élections primaires car
le sort du canal est devenu un symbole
d'une longue série d'échecs de la
politique étrangère américaine
le canal et sa zone ont été concédés aux
états unis en perpétuité il y à 70 ans
mais la république de panama exigent
maintenant de les récupérer
en fait les américains savent que le
canal n'a plus le rôle stratégique
économique d'antan ni les porte avions
ni les supertankers ne peuvent emprunter
ses écluses mais le canal est devenue
une véritable petite amérique voiture et
skol boutique même les pompiers cédé au
panaméen serait pour beaucoup
d'américains une reculade une défaite de
plus comme le vietnam comme l'angola
comme la détente alors l'adversaire
conservateur de ford renault mégane
s'est emparé de la sphère du canal de
panama
nous avons construit ce canal nous
l'avons payé et nous appartient affirme
régal nous en retirer dit il serait
laissé s'installer une base soviétique
qui menacerait directement notre pays en
fait
reagan c'est que les républicains qui
prennent la peine de voter dans les
primaires sont les vrais croyants les
plus conservateurs et donc les plus
sensibles à ce thème d'une menace sur le
canal le président ford doit plaire à
ses électeurs très conservateur pour
obtenir la nomination de son parti il
lui est donc impossible de prendre des
initiatives audacieuses en matière de
politique étrangère ni peut-il réagir
aux événements d'une manière imaginative
par exemple si les communistes entre
dans le gouvernement italien son choix
de réponse est limité car si ford accès
se fait ou l'approuver reagan l'accusera
immédiatement de s'être vendu aux
communes mais si des événements
dangereux ou d'une très grande
importance survenait je ne doute
absolument pas que le gouvernement
américain a les moyens d'y répliquer
efficacement dans la james river sur la
côté est des milliers de navires de
guerre dorn enveloppés dans du plastique
en réserve
il y a un arsenal énorme incidents des
bases à travers les états-unis avions
tanks navire en cas de besoin ils
peuvent être prêt à servir en une
semaine
ces bateaux endormi il symbolise la
puissance américaine toujours la
première du monde mais négligée au
profit des problèmes intérieurs est
limitée par un dégoût pour les aventures
étrangères certes il y a eu des échecs
mais le potentiel des états unis est
toujours présent et peut s'affirmer
dès qu'il le faudra
phan van est à l'hôpital à washington
aux inconnus mais état sérieux
on avait fait les v2 d'hitler ou
souvenez mais aussi il avait fait la
fusée qui a permis aux américains
d'aller sur la lune
frank sinatra lui va se marier ou se
remarier ce sera la quatrième fois sa
fiancée suzy porte déjà une bague
d'engagement comme on dit ici avec un
diamant gros comme l'himalaya
les américains passent pour des gens
très froid comme tous les anglo saxons
et pourtant je voudrais vous montrer
quelques images que l'on peut voir tous
les jours ici à la télévision regardez
ce n'est pas une réunion électorale un
peu acheté ni même les préliminaires
d'un match de boxe de caps ses mines
ce n'est qu'un jeu télévisé comme on en
voit cinq ou six par jour à la
télévision américaine
m
enfin
où il est présenté par l'équivalent de
nos fiers bellemare ou guy lux il
consiste tout bêtement deviner le prix
d'un objet à l'objet cher cette montre
vaut plus de 3000 francs il veut gagner
l'heureuse gagnante et ses supporters
cette émission est passé à six billets
s'il ya moins de deux heures
vous ai longuement expliqué au début de
ce journal que l'amérique est en train
de se choisir un président c'est la
question du jour
mais je vous rappelle quand on oublie
souvent que les américains aient listes
en même temps leurs députés
le gouverneur et même leur chéri ce qui
souvent est beaucoup plus important pour
eux que le président des états unis
dans ses carnets de voyage michel
toulouse a rencontré un candidat chérif
impossible d'être élu chérif sans
publicité mais il en coûte seulement 400
francs pour faire passer une annonce à
la télévision régionale
quatre candidats se présentent à corpus
christi ont choisi de suivre
solomont ortiz il est le premier
candidat mexicain américain a postulé au
texas
même chez mac bonne campagne
présidentielle mais sur le monde va
serrer des mains
seul sur le môle mène sa campagne en
d'hollande américains et mexicains
car les mexicains représentent la moitié
de la population de corpus christi la
frontière mexicaine n'est pas très loin
les mexicains devient de plus en plus
nombreux dans les états du sud
ils forment la frange la plus pauvre de
la population ils disent nous sommes les
nouveaux noir des etats unis
et on s'occupe peu de nous le rôle d'un
shérif patron de la police municipale
pour quatre ans le thème le plus débattu
la vente libre des armes doivent enlever
les armes à ceux qui les possèdent
si vous faites ça les criminels sont
procureront toujours et vous aurez le
même programme
tous ceux qui possèdent une maison
doivent avoir en france pour empêcher
leur maison la corruption autres thèmes
favoris de solomon il est vrai que la
place de chérif peut être très
intéressante
j'imagine qu'il ya de la corruption car
je suis surpris mais ici nous avons le
crime organisé la corruption règne dans
tout bon début comment fait-on pour oran
tranche est riche par exemple par
exemple le jeu la première est clair
vous avez les maisons en jeu et vous
venez pas me voir vous me donnez moi et
je ne vous avais 15 puis sur le trottoir
voilà c'est en francs ne les dérangeait
pas nous ne voulons pas tous risques en
europe soit rico une cinquantaine de ce
lot van eeckhout 50 mille francs
sinon c'est nous at il dit par les très
riches et les très pauvres les pauvres
les mexicains organise des lotos comme
ici vente des crêpes des fleurs pour
financer sa campagne
les riches ont donné 30 mille francs
ils ont conscience en solomon pour
nettoyer la ville il a été officier de
police
au texas suivant la loi
chaque candidat doit indiquer d'où lui
vient l'argent et comment il l'a dépensé
je veux tu être lui parce que le shérif
est responsable de la prison dans le
comté nous avons 150 prisonniers de
nouveaux arrivent chaque jour ces
prisonniers viennent des quartiers peau
chérif peut engager les programmes pour
les former oui comme ça mais quand ils
sortiront de prison ils pourront rentrer
dans la société
c'est important je veux les aider je
veux créer en prison une école de
cuisine de couture aider les prisonniers
avoir leur diplôme et ainsi seront bien
préparés à rentrer dans la société
le bal est organisé aussi pour les
caisses de solomon
les élections auront lieu le 5 juin sur
le mans affrontera l'ancien shérif
mais aujourd'hui les moeurs ont bien
changé au texas
l'un des combattants ne se retrouvera
pas au son des cercueils les urnes en
décideront
le concorde continue à polémiquer ici
les habitants de washington
reconnaissent que le premier norris car
destin n'a pas fait tellement de bruit
en arrivant chez eux avec cet oiseau de
malheur mais en fait toujours la fine
bouche pourtant en cette année du
bicentenaire puisqu'on parle tellement
histoire en ce moment et spécialement
aujourd'hui on raconte ici cette
anecdote quand la france décidé
d'envoyer un corps expéditionnaire en
amérique il ya 200 ans on a cherché le
moyen le plus rapide pour avertir nos
alliés on a trouvé une frégate plus
rapide du monde les américains
l'attendaient avec impatience
elle s'appelait concours voilà je vous
aurais tout dit en vous précisant qu'il
fait toujours très très mauvais très
froid sur la côte est où nous nous
trouvons 3° à washington plus chaud dans
le sud au texas avec 18 degrés ou le
président giscard d'estaing se rendra
demain j'espère donc un rayon de soleil
dans notre édition de demain soir ainsi
à tourner le monde aujourd'hui toute
l'équipe d'antenne 2 en 1
eric vous dit bonsoir et souhaite vous
retrouvez en direct demain grâce au
satellite de communications grâce aussi
à la cie billets ses atouts nos
confrères et amis américains bonsoir
et bien si les jeux sont faits à new
york il nous reste quelques chiffres à
tirer à paris transition habile pour
vous annoncer les résultats du premier
loto national je vous rappelle que seuls
les habitants de paris et de la région
parisienne pouvait y jouer sera bientôt
d'ailleurs le tour de la province
d'après les spécialistes le premier loto
a été un succès j'ai pas osé dire un
cadeau oui d'un loto à l'autre le tirage
du premier loto français a eu lieu tout
à l'heure il ya un peu moins d'une demi
heure
c'est un succès puisque pour la seule
région parisienne les enjeux ont atteint
la somme de 64 millions d'anciens francs
soit le double de la somme joué lors du
premier tirage du loto allemand vous
savez qu'il faut trouver six numéros
voici ses numéros sortis de la machine
le 31 le case le 33
le 27 le 36 est le 48 puisse 1/7 une
sorte de joker le 34 avec 3 seulement de
ses six numéros vous avez gagné
mais si vous avez les 6 et le super gros
lot à 50 milles contre un soin pour ce
tirage la somme de 10 millions d'anciens
francs environ pour deux frères les
rapports précis seront publiés par la
presse dans 48 la mâture maintenant pour
constater d'abord qu'aujourd'hui le ciel
rester nuageux dans l'ensemble il a fait
tout de même beaucoup plus frère il
températures variant entre 11 et 19
degrés demain le temps va rester orageux
en particulier de l'alsace à la corse
sur le reste du pays beaucoup de nuages
et même de la pluie sur les ardennes le
massif central est aussi la température
est toujours accusé une légère baisse
gérard holtz vous prépare la dernière
édition pour 23 heures après le magazine
c'est à dire que vous présentez jean
marie cavada et dont le grand témoin
sera monsieur michel jobert je vous
souhaite une re soirée à demain